[Musik]
jetzt bleibt aus köln
der presseclub mit mmi hallo und
herzlich willkommen zu diesem presseclub
eigentlich finden wir überhaupt keine
worte mehr dafür was sich gerade in
großbritannien abspielt wir haben uns
schon die augen gerieben wie waren
verzweifelt oder schockiert vielleicht
sind einige auch gleichgültig oder
genervt kurzum das was dort gerade
passiert das hat es noch nie gegeben in
london stehen sich zwei politische lager
unerbittlich wie noch nie gegenüber auf
der einen seite der britische
premierminister boys johnson er will
raus aus der eu um jeden preis ohne
rücksicht auf verluste
hauptsache es klappt zum 31 oktober
dafür schickt er das parlament in die
zwangspause und lässt die so wie er sie
nennt verräter aus der eigenen fraktion
kurzerhand ausschließen ein zitat von
ihm lieber tot im graben liegen als um
eine verlängerung zu bitten
auf der anderen seite da rebellieren
jetzt die parlamentarier in einer
bislang völlig undenkbaren allianz über
alle parteigrenzen hinweg
sie wollen ein modell exit also ein
austritt ohne vertrag um jeden preis
verhindern und auch hier ein zitat sie
wollen boris johnson erst mal in seinem
eigenen saft schmoren lassen
unglaubliche szenen in einem land das
für sich in anspruch nimmt die mutter
der demokratie zu sein
nehmen sie sich sein guter junge ruft
der sprecher des unterhauses diskutiert
hier wirklich ein parlament über die
zukunft des landes großbritannien kennt
lebhafte debatten aber so mit aller
macht versucht premierminister johnson
in brax it durchzuboxen
der abgeordnete philipp ii wechselt
während der sitzung die fraktion cloud
dem premierminister damit die mehrheit
ich habe es satt die sprache die hier
gesprochen wird und wie die leute fertig
gemacht
boris johnson wiederum drohte im
parlament wirft abgeordnete die gegen
ihn gestimmt haben aus der partei
darunter auch altehrwürdige mitglieder
des parlaments die den enkel von winston
churchill
ich habe 37 jahre lang diesem haus
gedient und es hat mich mit immensem
stolz erfüllt ich bin sehr traurig dass
es so enden muss großbritannien kämpft
um seine zukunft
die fronten sind verhärtet er denn je da
kann selbst der und aus sprecher kaum
noch durchgreifen
dadurch greifen es schwierig aber
durchblicken wird auch immer schwieriger
was mag jetzt noch als nächstes
passieren ist der no deal jetzt wirklich
vom tisch wird boris johnson seine
neuwahlen bekommen wird der praxis
tatsächlich nochmal verschoben
und was müsste jetzt eigentlich die eu
tun fragen über fragen für die wir jetzt
versuchen werden antworten zu finden im
presseclub zum thema das britische drama
gibt es einen ausweg aus der braig cit
krise und ich freue mich ganz besonders
über meine gäste cathrin kahlweit sie
ist london korrespondent in der
süddeutschen zeitung und sie sagt die
opposition in london sollte die
drohungen von jetzt von beuys johnson
einfach aussitzen
mit in der runde ist auch ursula
weidenfeld sie arbeitet als freie
wirtschaftsjournalistin berlin und sagt
europa schaut ratlos zu wie beuys
johnson zuerst seine partei und dann
sein land zerlegt herzlich willkommen
heißt ich eric bonse freier journalist
aus brüssel der unter anderem für die
taz und den cicero schreibt er meint
dass die eu angesichts des britischen
dramas nicht passiv auf der
zuschauerbank bleiben darf und ich
begrüße besonders gray lukas freier
journalist aus england der mittlerweile
mit deutschem pass in deutschland lebt
und unter anderem für phoenix berichtet
er wünscht sich ein zweites referendum
mit der option in der eu zu verbleiben
seien sie alle herzlich willkommen die
erste frage herr lukas geht heute
natürlich an sisi als brite in dieser
runde schildern sie uns doch mal ihre
gefühlslage mit welchen emotionen
fassungslosigkeit ähnlichem haben sie
diese woche erlebt also ich bin sehr
beunruhigt das will ich gar nicht zu
stecken also man erlebt eine exit
bewegung die immer radikale wird und man
sieht jetzt wie boris johnson im
parlament agiert da gibt es keine gnade
für gegner und im grunde genommen hat
kann man sie ja sagen
der bock hat lange am zaun gerüttelt und
jetzt hat man ihn zum gärtner gemacht
und das chaos ist jetzt da und niemand
weiß so genau was jetzt passieren wird
die die britischen journalisten wissen
genauso wenig wie die anderen und man
hat das gefühl die weisheit von heute
ist der unsinn von morgen also die die
abläufe der nachrichten werden immer
schneller und immer mehr unsinn kommt
auf den tisch wir werden sehen was
geschieht scheinbar gab es am freitag
diskussionen zwischen dem britischen
vertreter von boris johnson und der eu
dies so einem eklat geführt haben
da weiß man inzwischen ziemlich
sprachlos
vielleicht ganz kurz noch mal auf ihre
persönliche gefühlslage also sie sind ja
brite und auch deutsche
sie gucken vielleicht noch ein bisschen
anders darauf also mit sind sie jetzt
wütend dass irland dass es da so weit
kommen konnte sind sie traurig sind sie
die analyse die politischen betreiben
wir haben gleich noch aber so also was
macht es mit ihnen ich meine wir sind
glaube ich auch alle erschüttert und
fassungslos aber wenn es noch mal das
eigene land ist ist es vielleicht
nochmal was an ja also ich bin nach
deutschland gekommen
ende der siebziger jahre als student und
habe in bonn politologie studiert und
nicht zuletzt bei professor karl
dietrich bracher und mein hauptinteresse
war das der fall der weimarer republik
und natürlich blicke ich auf die jetzige
zeit und denke gut es ist nicht eine
wiederholung der geschichte aber das
sind elemente die verblüffend ähnlich
sind und man macht sich natürlich sorgen
weil man einfach nicht weiß zu welchen
maßnahmen boris johnson jetzt greifen
wird wird erst zum beispiel tatsächlich
ein beschluss des parlaments ignorieren
und dann auch noch ein urteil des
obersten gerichts also das weiß man im
moment nicht und man macht sich
natürlich sorgen dass die demokratien
diese weise ausgehöhlt wird und dass die
menschen dass es einfach respekt fürs
parlament verlieren wir gehen ja gleich
noch in die einzelnen nächsten schritte
was möglicherweise noch kommen kann also
wir werden uns beraten darüber aber
vorher sagen können es natürlich auch
nicht frau karl weil sie berichten jetzt
direkt sozusagen aus dem herzen dieser
ganzen dramatischen ereignisse aus
london was überwiegt denn bei ihnen
nach dieser woche also die der stolz
darauf dass das parlament sich so
zusammen gerissen hat und jetzt versucht
boris johnson macht entgegen zu setzen
oder die der frust die fassungslosigkeit
darüber wie beust johnson agiert als
premierminister
ich war wenige stunden stolz auf dieses
parlament weil es so unerwartet kam
und ich hatte für ein paar stunden
tatsächlich das gefühl da könnte sich
etwas gedreht haben aber diese dieser
optimismus von dem ich weiß dass er
immer nur kurz währt wurde sehr schnell
sozusagen überlagert von der sorge dass
das teil eines sozusagen mit mit
machiavellistischen plans ist von
dominik hammes dem chefberater von
johnson um natürlich damit von johnson
selbst und die ereignisse der letzten
zwei tage bestätigen nicht eigentlich
eher in dem gefühl dass es sonst
ziemlich egal ist wie sehr sich das
parlament jetzt ermahnt und dein blödes
wort zu benutzen und wie sehr sie gegen
wir leisten gegen diese politik weil die
neuesten nachrichten aus london
noch beunruhigender sind als alles was
ich in den letzten wochen schon gehört
habe dass johnson mit einer fehlenden
mehrheit agieren muss war jetzt ja klar
dass er mit dem rücktritt der
arbeitsministerin gestern sozusagen eine
minderheit noch vergrößert ist auch klar
aber was jetzt passiert ist offenbar
dass er beschlossen hat diese
verlängerung nicht zu beantragen
als sozusagen obstruktionspolitik in
diesem gipfel zu gehen und den not wie
die briten sagen beide ford zu erzwingen
also sozusagen aus versehen und das
alles hat die basis dass er das gesetz
ignorieren will
und hinterher als strahlender zerstörer
in neue waren da steht letzter satz dazu
dieser domenica - von dem immer alle
sprechen ist so ein bisschen der steam
brennen von großbritannien und er hat
inzwischen eine macht die mir angst
machen
jetzt müssen wir vielleicht für sie sind
ja sehr tief jetzt drin ist unglücklich
nein nein alles gut alles gut er jetzt
muss er vielleicht noch mal für unsere
normalen zuschauer sahen sie habe jetzt
gerade vom exit bei die vor ort oder die
exit bei die ford gesprochen also werden
wir jetzt auch versuchen auszurollen was
da als nächstes noch alles so passieren
kann
glauben sie denn frau weidenfeld das
tatsächlich boys johnson das alles mag
realistisch geplant hat und er sozusagen
weiter hohes risiko spielt alles
mit einberechnet hat was jetzt passiert
also hat keine regierungsmehrheit mehr
er steht eigentlich alleine da er sagt
mit dem kopf durch die wand ist mir egal
ich stehe in brüssel und sagen ich habe
nichts und ich werde die schon gehörig
unter druck setzen was meinen sie
alle die boris johnson getroffen haben
sagen das ist ein spieler der also der
kennt nicht den kompromiss der kennt
nicht das politische prozedere des
verhandelns des findens von gemeinsamen
positionen sondern es ist ein spieler
der eben schwarz oder rot spielt und er
spielt jetzt eben auf brett auf und zwar
egal was da kommt und das hat er ja auch
gesagt und nimmt dafür in kauf dass aber
die politische mitte sowohl auf der
linken die auf der rechten in
großbritannien völlig zerfällt dass sie
weg ist und egal was nun passiert in den
nächsten wochen wir werden auch wenn es
neuwahlen gebe mit einer komplett
anderen britische demokratie zu tun
haben weil eben die politische mitte
also diejenigen die vielleicht
verhandeln die vielleicht kompromisse
auch suchen weil die praktisch in mit
dieser woche ausgelöscht sind aus dem
politischen aus der politischen realität
londons zumindest jetzt erstmal für die
nächsten monate und das ist glaube ich
dass das hauptproblem boris johnson hat
durch dieses ja oder nein schwarz oder
rot durch dieses spieler hafte
tatsächlich das zerstört was politisch
oder was die westlichen demokratien
immer geprägt haben nämlich diejenigen
die am ende in der lage sind den
kompromiss zu finden mit dem man aus
einer sache so rauskommt dass auch
diejenigen die dagegen sind oder die
minderheiten die das nicht wollen in der
lage sind es zu ertragen und das mit zu
tragen also die frage wieviel
gemeinsamkeit wie viel
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt hat man
in einem land wird ja eben immer
beschrieben von denen die den kompromiss
gefunden haben und das scheint in
großbritannien nicht mehr möglich und
auch nicht mehr nötig zu sein vielleicht
nur an siehe bonn sind die frage also
mit diesem schwarz oder rot spiel hat
sich bei johnson ja aber trotzdem jetzt
in eine ganz schöne sackgasse manövriert
na also er ist sozusagen in
eigene im eigenen parlament mit der
regierung nicht mehr mehrheitsfähig
nicht mehr handlungsfähig scheint ihm
aber möglicherweise ganz egal zu sein
und er könnte wirklich zum
entscheidenden brüssel gipfel mitte
oktober reisen und sagen leute ich hab
nix ich setzt euch die pistole auf die
brust
meinen sie das kann irgendwie auf gehen
also fest dass kanada passieren
aus ihrer sicht tja in brüssel ist man
auch ziemlich ratlos was da passieren
kann
die lage ändert sich ja praktisch
stündlich visier einer auswanderung
berichtet haben wenn man sieht dass nach
außen hin mit einer großen gelassenheit
fast schon british school die ansage der
eu-kommission die wir jeden tag hören
ist eigentlich unsere türen stehen offen
24 stunden am tag sieben tage die woche
wir warten auf vorschläge auf sondern
dann können wir in ruhe darüber reden
dahinter hinter den kulissen wenn man da
mit dem diplomaten spricht hört man
natürlich ganz andere dinge
fassungslosigkeit völliges unverständnis
auch empörung über den auftritt von
johnson wenn er dann behauptet die
verhandlungen gingen also wunderbar
voran habe fortschritte gemacht es gibt
de facto keine verhandlungen oder wenn
er jetzt neulich diesen diese neue
sprachregelung wählt kollaborateure im
britischen parlament und die europäische
union sozusagen als feind fast wie im
faschismus das ist natürlich
unerträglich in europäischen ohren
und wenn man dann noch weiter bord dann
spürt man die europäische union ist auch
ratlos sie hält sich an dem ziel fest
die klammert sich an den deal denn
theresa may ausgehandelt hat aber de
facto politisch zumindest ist dieser
deal doch tot seit boris johnson an 24
siebten demonstriert übernommen hat
würde gerne noch einen kurzen nachsatz
machen weil sie mich zitiert habe und
ich war unpräzise es ist ziemlich egal
ob er eine mehrheit im parlament
verlieren natürlich ist es schwierig
innerhalb der tory partei gibt es jetzt
verwerfungen viele haben das gefühl die
partei die sie kannten existiert nicht
mehr die rauswürfe haben natürlich
selbst für sehr viel erregung gesorgt
die frage ist nur steckt auch dahinter
ein konzept ja natürlich weil es in den
umfragen sich positiv niederschlägt man
kann das ganz schwer nachvollziehen aber
es ist tatsächlich so dass boris johnson
nach dieser woche in dem man das gefühl
hat er ist in eine ecke gedrängt worden
hat verloren und verloren eine
abstimmung nach der anderen er hat die
partei quasi zerlegt
sind seine umfragewerte gestiegen das
ist das was in dornick speed überlegt
wird wir mögen zwar das parlament
bestätigen aber das parlament steht ja
gegen den bhc exit und das volk will den
berg sind und je mehr wir uns als die
echten rexit kämpfer inszenieren und je
mehr wird das parlament klein machen
umso mehr wird das volk uns lieben und
das ist etwas das wir ähnlich auch in
den usa eher nicht genau also wir sehen
ja eigentlich auch also donald trump der
oft mit boris johnson auch verglichen
wird an der stelle macht dinge wo wir
sagen ja wir jetzt muss doch mal genug
sein
bei seinen fans oder bei seinen
anhängern dort passiert das gegenteil
wir sagen mensch der steht das ding
durch sehen sie das ähnlich also er hat
letztendlich boris johnson hat menschen
hinter sich die sagen ja guck mal der
zeigt dass endlich mal der will uns den
weg geben den wir haben wollen
und er zieht es durch ja das wird ja auf
jeden fall versuchen denke ich mal also
zunächst einmal will er die unterhaus
wahl haben und das waren das war das
ziel der vergangenen woche nur es hat
nicht geklappt weil die
oppositionsparteien im parlament ihm
einfach nicht über den weg trauen und
sie befürchten würden sie jetzt für
wahlen stimmen und er braucht ein zwei
drittel mehrheit könnte er einfach das
datum verschieden und es gab ja gerüchte
gerüchte aus ten downing street die
nicht wirklich dementiert wurden dass er
dann denkt er macht dann diese wahlen am
veranstaltet diese wahl am ersten
november also das gebe ihm die
möglichkeit ein new deal durchgehen zu
lassen und dann sich feiern zu lassen
als der held von breck cit am erster
november und natürlich haben die
oppositionsparteien gesagt nein das
werden wir nicht machen wir lassen ihm
im eigenen saft ein klein wenig schmoren
aber ich glaube sie wissen schon dass es
so eine wahl kommen wird weil im moment
obwohl ich es gerne sehen würde wird es
nicht zu einem zweiten referendum kommen
weil die mehrheitsverhältnisse im
parlament nicht da sind aber um auf
ihrem punkt zurückzukommen wenn es zu
dieser unter wahl unter hauswald kommt
in den nächsten monaten man redet von
november oder vielleicht realistische
ist im januar oder februar irgendwann
werden wir natürlich einmal ein
wahlkämpfer in wahlkampf szene im
zeichen von unabhängigkeit gegen
sozialismus was man gegen jeremy corbin
etwas unglücklichen chef der labour
partei zählt und natürlich exit also das
volk gegen das parlament also das werden
die beiden haupt strenger dieses
wahlkampfes seifen sie mir kurz zu
ordnen sie haben jetzt gesagt also
eigentlich johnsons planen dann wenn er
die neuwahlen bekommt diese auf den nach
dem 31 10 zu terminieren wann auch immer
sie dann stattfinden werden können wir
gleich noch weiter diskutieren aber es
gibt doch jetzt dieses gesetz was die
queen noch unterzeichnen muss also wo
eigentlich ein ungeregelter austritt
ausgeschlossen wurde kann sich boris
johnson da jetzt einfach drüber hinweg
selbst verstehe ich nicht erklären sie
es mir bitte ja also er sagt er wird es
tun und das ist da sind wir im moment
sagte wird einfach dieses gesetz
ignorieren und dann lässt er sich ein
auf einen juristischen kampf weil die
die oppositionsparteien sammeln schon
ihre anwälte und wollen klagen vor dem
supreme court also vor dem obersten
gericht aber dann ist natürlich für uns
völlig offen was dann da kommt also das
ist es nicht gesagt dass das gericht
gegen ihn entscheidet die schlagzeilen
heute
man kann sich kaum vorstellen in den
großen britischen medien heißen geht
boris für den praxis ins gefängnis ich
verkürze also er stellt sich jetzt hat
jemand da der greenback so sehr will
dass er im zweifel sich über das gesetz
hinwegsetzen wird was ihnen ja
eigentlich dazu zwingt in brüssel einen
vertrag vorzulegen oder auszuhandeln und
wenn nicht am 19 oktober um diese
verlängerung zu bitten
er sagt das wäre ich auf gar keinen fall
tun er wird sagen wenn ihr mich
verklagen wollte verklagt mich ich gehe
ins ins gefängnis aber auch das ist
möglicherweise teil eines plans man
denkt er inzwischen nur noch ein
verschwörungs theoretisch
so habe ich es heute würdigen times
gelesen dass davon ausgeht dass das
supreme court urteil also das urteil des
obersten gerichts nicht vor dem 31
oktober da ist und dann hätten wir
wieder das was ich eingangs gesagt habe
beck sind beide ford einen exit aus
versehen möglich ja nicht zwingend aber
möglich noch eine ergänzung in brüssel
hören wir immer johnson muss eine
verlängerung beantragen die kommt nicht
automatisch er muss die das ist
sozusagen die europäische darstellung
er muss es beantragen damit sie auf den
gipfel diskutiert werden kann und dann
müssen vernünftige gründe darlegen
solltest auch frau von der leyen schon
gesagt um möglicherweise eine weitere
verlängerung zu haben das heißt wenn er
das nicht macht wenn das nicht beantragt
wäre nach dieser argumentation die
europäische union ratlos und in der tat
die isar wechselt wurde am 31 10
sozusagen automatisch by default
eintreten und dann sollte man einzeln im
hinterkopf behalten der erste hälfte das
ist das datum an dem normalerweise die
neue eu-kommission unter von der leyen
anfangen soll staaten durchstarten soll
und zwar möglichst mit einem neustart
und nicht mit einem klotz am bein würde
ich jetzt mal sagen wie großbritannien
das in der sich innerlich völlig
zerstritten ist das eigentlich sich
nicht mehr als teil der europäischen
union fühlt dieser zeitplan könnte
natürlich völlig durcheinandergewirbelt
werden wenn es dann noch mal eine doch
noch eine verlängerung gibt noch mal
neue wahlmann bis januar wartet
möglicherweise noch länger
das heißt die handlungsfähigkeit der
europäischen union steht hier auch auf
dem spiel das geht nicht nur um johnson
und praxis gucken wir gleich noch auf
der eu ich hab noch mal eine
verständnisvolle entschuldigung sie
haben jetzt nein nein nein aber das ist
ja also ist aber wir haben ja hier
gesammelte kompetenz sie um zu versuchen
zu ergründen was jetzt möglich ist als
nächstes also wir sagen johnson ist
völlig egal dass es dieses gesetz gibt
er macht weiter auf seinem ticket er
sagt oliver beck cit am 31.10 gehen wir
raus ich werde natürlich auch in brüssel
keine verlängerung beantragen
dann geht die opposition zum supreme
court ich nehme an vergleichbar mit
unserem verfassungsgericht das gucken
kann wer hat denn jetzt in diesem
kompetenzen gefüge recht und sie sagen
dieses urteil könnte erst nach dem 31
das ist eine möglichkeit einer von zehn
möglich kein problem
es wird nur kompliziert auch nicht
versuche jetzt mich sozusagen in die
rolle des musikers zu begeben in dem ich
alle anderen komplizierten lösungen auch
noch aufzählen
möglichkeiten gibt es natürlich mehrere
es gibt die möglichkeit eines
misstrauensvotums gegen johnson dass er
auch das wird zurzeit ein dorn im street
offenbar diskutiert gegen sich selbst
einbringen könnte hat man auch noch
nicht so gesehen gesetz aber ich glaube
dass labour auch wenn es keine neuwaren
automatisch will nicht umhin könnte bei
einem misstrauensvotum gegen ihn zu
stimmen weil sie werden sonst nicht im
amt halten gesetzen fall das wäre der
fall und leber würde mit den anderen
oppositionsparteien in für diesen fall
dass johns und sagt ich mache das alles
nicht versuchen eine übergangsregierung
zu bilden
droht also sind immer noch drohungen wir
reden hier ja nur vom konjunktiv droht
johnson dann nicht zurückzutreten was
verfassungsrechtlich möglich ist dass
ist alles aus getestet worden das heißt
es könnte sein es gibt einen
misstrauensvotum gegen den
premierminister der premierminister sagt
ist mir auch egal bleibe ich aber im amt
das heißt wir hätten dann quasi zwar
auch wer ist er wirklich es ist möglich
wir hätten eine gegenregierung und um
diese neue noch weiter auszuweiten auch
das ist an diesem wochenende wenn ich
der times in telegraph und im guardian
glaube in downing street diskutiert
wurden das was sie gerade beschrieben
haben obstruktionspolitik in brüssel zu
betreiben zum einen natürlich immer noch
ist ja wie wir wissen großbritannien
mitglied der eu das heißt also immer da
wo das einstimmigkeitsprinzip in frage
steht
mit nein zu stimmen das könnte doch die
dauer sehr ärgerlich werden und zum
zweiten keinen kommissar zu bestellen
jetzt bin ich keine europarechtlich war
ich habe gelesen dass die eu-kommission
sich darf darauf schon ein stellt und
sagt wir können auch ohne einen
britischen kommissar am ersten november
anfangen der handlung street sagt das
geht nicht dann müsst ihr uns
rausschmeißen
ok jetzt sagen aber eben eine ganz ganz
kurz ganz kurz zu diesem punkt aus der
laut lissabon-vertrag soll die eu
kommission in ohnehin verkleinert werden
das wäre sozusagen jetzt die goldene
chance
gelegenheit dazu sagen na gut wenn die
briten nicht wollen da hab da eben kein
kommissar und short halt nur zu dass es
schon wert hat wenn länder eine
geschriebene verfassung haben
was haben die briten nicht und im viel
von dem was wir im moment diskutieren
hat halt eben damit zu tun dass es keine
geschriebene verfassung gibt und
man eben sich in einem sehr sehr großen
graubereich bewegt was die frage der
rechtmäßigkeit der des verhaltens der
politischen regierung angeht aber ich
glaube wir müssen schon auch sagen es
gibt ja noch ein eu gipfel an dem die
briten teilnehmen werden mitte oktober
und es gibt ja auch die leser zu sagen
der spieler johnson spielt bis zur
letzten bis zum letzten skitour also das
spiel bis zur letzte bis zum letzten tag
und möglicherweise gibt es ja dann an
diesem mitte oktober gipfel noch etwas
was er mitbringt ein vorschlag den er
hat das ist nicht moment wirklich sieht
es nicht danach aus ist auch nicht
besonders wahrscheinlich aber man kann
es ja nicht ausschließen
also ich denke man muss gerade wenn man
abschätzt ob es im letzten augenblick
ein deal geben kann oder nicht muss man
schon berücksichtigen dass wie ich
eingangs gesagt habe die hardliner sind
jetzt dann macht und hardliner haben
frau may zu fall gebracht weil frau aus
ihrer sicht einen deal gemacht hat und
was großbritannien zu nah an der
europäischen union positioniert das
wollen sie nicht das heißt sie wollen
weiter zurück diese deal von frau may
war ihnen einfach nicht akzeptabel aus
vielerlei gründen nicht zuletzt weil es
bedeutet hätte dass man eine zeit eine
übergangszeit hätte er gehabt hätte wo
man die freihandelsabkommen selber nicht
hätten abschließen können in aller welt
vor allen dingen mit den usa das heißt
diese radikalität wird glaube ich von
der von der europäischen union
unterschätzt
also bei den black sea tieren gibt es
halt ein modell das nennen sie singer
pur an der themse
das scheint ihr leitfaden zu sein das
heißt deregulierungen abschaffung von
eu-vorschriften usw schaffung von
standards eher niedrige löhne damit man
es war eine eine export wirtschaft
ankurbeln kann und vor allen dingen
niedrige steuer und wir wissen ja auch
von figuren wie
jacob smog der jetzt sozusagen die
geschäfte im parlament organisiert das
ist der der da das schläfchen gemacht
hat er genau seit spätestens seitdem ist
er in deutschland bekannt
das ist dein kopf diese bewegung und sie
bewegen sich sehr nahe bei den libyens
in den usa und diese radikalität da ist
glaube ich natürlich schwer für die
europäische verstehen aber das ist jetzt
die treibende kraft und deswegen die
gespräche am freitag in brüssel die
scheiterten komplett weil die briten
vorgeschlagen haben ja die in die
republik irland sollte die möglichkeit
haben sich zu entfernen von europäischen
vorschriften damit die grenze auf bleibt
das ist nicht ein zoll union und die
briten geben nach sondern es ist wird
knacken die eu und das ist richtig ein
frontalangriff auf den binnenmarkt was
letzten endes ein gewisse kit für die
europäischen union ist und leuchtet wie
man schon verarscht die nach wie vor
viel einfluss im hintergrund haben sie
sagen ja auch das ziel ist die
zerstörung der eu hat kein interesse an
der es sagt ja auch heute morgen noch
mal warum wollen wir ein deal her wir
gehen raus und die eu wird dann
irgendwann mal an den inneren
widersprüchen kaputt gehen
sie wollten auch ich wollte das nur
fortführen die diese praxis von denen
wir darüber sprechen diese hardliner die
nennen sich selber ja spartaner allein
das sagt schon relativ viel diese
sportler haben zurzeit die regierung im
griff augenblicklich sagt johnson
ich schmeiße die sozusagen meine
liberalen gegner raus ich würde war auch
die spontane rausschmeißen wenn sie
gegen einen deal den ich mitbringen
höhere bestimmen würden das muss er
sagen logischerweise das problem ist
aber dass ich habe leute haben gleich
wird er nicht tun erstens und zweitens
wird er wird können nicht über einen
deal verhandelt
ich bin nicht ganz bei ihnen wenn sie
sagen die eu hat das nicht richtig
eingeschätzt oder kann das nicht
einschätzen ich glaube die wissen nein
ich bin sogar sicher die wissen ziemlich
genau aus allen gesprächen die ich höre
sie sind da
dann aber mit dem uno vertreten die ich
in london treffen die wissen ganz genau
mit wem sie es zu tun haben und sie
haben recht am freitag war david force
das ist der unterhändler von johnson in
brüssel und hat auf den tisch gelegt den
vorschlag den aktuellen vorschlag von
johnson der sieht so aus wir nehmen den
vertrag von mail streichen einfach den
berg stoppt also diese verhasster apple
johnson verhasste lösung weg und nicht
nur dort den den teil kennen wir schon
wir schlagen auch nichts neues vor
sondern wir wollen uns auch was sie
gerade gesagt haben bei allen allem was
regel regeln gibt die sind für umwelt
für landwirtschaft für sozusagen die
anpassung von standards die uns
ermöglicht in die eu zu exportieren
entfernen also alles das was sie
versprochen hat wir bleiben auf einem
level wird wir machen sozusagen
natürlich eu-freundliche wirtschaft
alles das wird gerade zurückgefahren und
das ist dramatisch weil es bedeutet dass
die dass großbritannien sich in diesen
verhandlungen nicht nur nicht nach vorn
bewegt sondern demonstrativ zurück
ganz kurz für die zuschauer noch mal
dieses back stopped problem also boris
johnson hat ja gesagt das schlimmste an
dem vertrag von frau may ist die
backstop klausel die backstop klausel
besagt habe ich mir jetzt hier auch
nochmal schwarz auf weiß aufgeschrieben
nordirland das ist ja vor allem das
problem grenze nordirland irland
nordirland soll bis auf weiteres in der
eu soll union und in teilen des
binnenmarkts verbleiben wenn man sich
nicht auf einen freihandelsvertrag
zwischen großbritannien und der ist man
sich bis man ganz wichtiger untersucht
bis man es wenig dass soetwas merkel die
platzhalter so das heißt die angst wenn
ich mich jetzt mal in die britische
seele versetzte die angst ist mit der
backstop klausel ist man sozusagen für
immer in der zollunion und in teilen des
binnenmarktes an von vasallenstaat genau
ist man da drin kann nicht mit den usa
freihandelsabkommen abschließen oder
singapur werden oder wie auch immer
und jetzt also diese back stopped aus
und hätte ich jetzt nämlich auch hier
gefragt wenn boys johnson seinen letzten
joker irgendwann im oktober in brüssel
auf den tisch legt müsste er daran ja
irgendetwas tun und wer habe ich jetzt
richtig verstanden ist das was
boris johnson vorschlägt zusagen nicht
nordirland soll so bleiben wie irlands
und dann andersrum irland das land es in
der eu bleibt soll sich auf die
mindeststandards von großbritannien
unter schreier und das ist natürlich für
die europäische union keiner weise
hinnehmbar darauf werden sie nicht
einlassen deswegen hat sie auch diese
mir klar am freitag gegeben dass es
schon klar
allerdings hat steht die europäische
union auch vor einem dilemma und zwar
ist das mit dem namen may und wächst
dort wiederum verbunden frau may hat ja
auch schon versucht diesen weg stop in
irgendeiner weise zu modifizieren
das unterhaus hat sicher damit
beauftragt und sie ist genau daran
gescheitert sie hat es zweimal versucht
ist zweimal hat sich zwei mal eine
blutige nase und brüssel geholt das
heißt in brüssel weist man schon sehr
genau wie brisant diese diese klausel
ist dieser werkstoff und eins muss man
auch dazu sagen das ist ja meist nicht
so bewusst bei sind wächst ob geht es ja
nicht in aller erster linie gar nicht
nur um die sicherung des historischen
friedens nach dem nordirland abkommen
nach dem dublin sondern es geht im
grunde genommen nachdem gut freeman es
geht im grunde genommen aus europäischer
sicht auch um die sicherung des
binnenmarkts
es geht auch um die frage wie können wir
verhindern dass da eine grenze
hochgezogen wird eine harte grenze oder
eine zollgrenze und das ist natürlich
irgendwo auch ein problem letzten endes
haben 31.10 wenn es zum harten praxis
kommen sollte dann müssten nämlich die
europäer wurde die ihren müssten dann da
grenzkontrollen einführen nicht die
briten und muss ich noch lehrern
angekündigt genau irische regierung
gesagt werden
grenznahe ist gelernter für die
europäischen union in das wollten wir
natürlich irland nicht dann hätte zudem
die europäische union den schwarzen
peter
und es würde all diese historischen
probleme auch wieder aufwerfen und
aufbrechen lassen wie man gerade
verwalten das ist das haupt das
hauptproblem ist eben einfach es war
einfach niemand wie ein solcher
vorschlag aussehen kann also mehreren
das formell zweimal damit gescheitert
ist sondern es gibt einfach keine idee
wie das sein kann also wie kann man
vermeiden dass es zwischen nordirland
und irland eine grenze gibt ohne dass
man eine grenze zwischen nord
land und dem englischen festland hat
oder umgekehrt also das wie das gehen
kann
das weiß niemand und eben unabhängig
davon wie konstruktiv oder wie
destruktiv die britische regierung sich
in europa aufführt ist eben bisher noch
kein vorschlag von von keiner seite
irgendwie sichtbar der sagen würde wir
können das problem in irgendeiner form
zufriedenstellend lösen ohne diesen back
stopped das ist richtig und ein
konservatives think tank hat gerade etwa
90 seiten produziert über dieses problem
mit dem ergebnis dass man sich das
angeguckt hatte sagte das funktioniert
nicht das ist so eine sammelsurium von
diversen vorschlägen technisch gibt es
sie ja gar nicht also man überlegt sich
ob man so quasi die last an scania
vorbeifahren lässt und social sachen um
es ganz auf simpelste niveau zu simpel
ist das niveau zu reduzieren und sonst
und hat sogar diese vorschläge die schon
ziemlich abwegig sind dann halt in
seiner verhandlungsstrategie intrigiert
integriert das heißt das zeigt schon wie
er vorgeht es ist nicht so ernst und wie
wieder
die ministerin bot die gestern
zurückgetreten ist gesagt hat ich sehe
es so gut wie keine vorbereitung keine
ernsthafte vorbereitung neu delhi zwei
hinter da ist jetzt mein punkt wo ich
dann auch mal mit brüssel ein bisschen
über kreuz liege ich denke es wäre
ureigenes interesse der europäischen
union sich dann selber mal gedanken zu
machen ob es nicht da doch einen
kompromiss geben kann niemand das war
bisher immer die historische
errungenschaft und das hervorstechende
merkmal der europäischen union dass sie
oft kompromisse setzt dass sie also
schwere politische konflikte zum teil
historische konflikte und
kriegssituation der kriegerische
spannung gelöst hat durch politische
kompromisse und das vermisse ich jetzt
in dieser neuen historischen lage ich
werde überleben immer zustimmen aber ich
glaube gegen die frage kann wenn welcher
kompromiss der aus brüssel kommt ist in
london in irgendeiner form sagt ist
aktionsfähig also ich glaube dass das
ist das große problem sie haben recht
wenn alle um eine lösung
bemüht wert wären würden seien würde es
möglicherweise auch irgendwann eine
geben aber wenn europa wenn brüssel
einen vorschlag macht oder irgendein
anderes mitgliedsland einen vorschlag
machen würde oder irland es sei denn
wiedervereinigung irlands oder was auch
immer
das würde in london nicht durchgehend
fallen dass man vor allen dingen läuft
man wirklich die gefahr dass johnson
sich umdrehte postwendend sagt sie
mischen sich eine in unsere innere
angelegenheiten und deswegen ist es
extrem schwierig für die eu überhaupt
tätig zu werden weil frauchen johnson
warten nur darauf dass die eu ein
bisschen druck ausübt und sagt hier ist
ein gangbarer weg da werden die durch
die decke gehen und sie werden da die
hälfte der bevölkerung mitnehmen
aber wenn man es selber immer an den
herrn bonse anzuknüpfen wenn es jetzt
nicht so wäre dass man druck macht
sondern sie haben ja schon geschildert
es ist auch jetzt lange seitens brüssel
nichts passiert wenn die eu jetzt etwas
tun würde was wie ein zückerchen oder
ein entgegenkommen oder was auch immer
aussehen könnte
gäbe es eine chance dass das nicht als
einmischung aufgefasst wird
nein nein ich finde ich bin natürlich
kompromiss ist ganz großartig
ich war bin seit zwei jahren eigentlich
sehr pessimistischen denke mal es muss
auf no deal rauslaufen weil ich war
viele nordirland ich sehe keine lösung
alles was bisher diskutiert worden ist
ein time limit das hat ja also ein zeit
eine zeitliche begrenzung des desktops
eine eine befristung sache mal auf fünf
jahre mit gleichzeitigen
parallelverhandlungen ist ja alles
möglicherweise etwas was rüber man hätte
reden können ist aber schon während ist
ausgesprochen wurde von den spartanern
zurückgewiesen worden das heißt was wir
sehen ist jeder kompromiss wird
zermahlen in dem britischen betrieb
bevor er überhaupt jeweils sozusagen in
eine ernsthafte diskussion hätte gehen
können genauso die der vorschlag
tatsächlich diesen werkstoff nochmal in
der politischen deklaration das ist ja
der zweite teil dieses ist abkommens
noch mal etwas ausführlicher zu
beschreiben oder oder oder
sobald brüssel sagt wir hätten da wir
sind gesprächsbereit kommen die
spartaner also die kleinen
existiert und sagen kein kompromiss gar
kein backstop und egal wie das aussieht
wir machen dieses ding nur ohne werk
stopp und zur jetzt stellen wir uns mal
vor brüssel würde sagen okay wir
verzichten auf den back stopped ich bin
immer gerne das bild das ist wäre so als
wenn man ein baby in einen löwenkäfig
legt und sagt benehmt euch jungs das
wird schon nichts passieren dass es wird
geht wird natürlich schiefgehen aber
selbst wenn brüssel diese kompromisse
machen würde es nicht dann stehen die
spartaner schon wieder da und sagen ja
aber jetzt sind er noch die 39
milliarden und dann ist da noch die
restitution des europäischen
gerichtshofes und dann sind da noch frei
das heißt die liste die es gibt um
dieses gesamte abkommen zu torpedieren
jenseits des werkstoffs ist so lang dass
wir wieder am anfang da sind ja diese
regierung will notiert aber jetzt muss
ich doch also wenn das alles so schlimm
ist wie sie jetzt beschreiben dann muss
ich doch an der stelle noch mal fragen
kann es wirklich sein dass beuys johnson
mit diesen absoluten harakiri kurs dann
immer noch die mehrheit der briten
hinter sich hat wenn man das alles
mehrheitswahlsystem ja weil ich anderes
mal so stehen kann es sein dass dann
trotzdem immer noch so viele menschen
ihm folgen wenn dieser kurs quasi
wirklich auf absolutes politisches
desaster ausgelegt ist so kann man es
schon angedeutet wir haben die
verhängnisvolle situation dass der
oppositionsführer jeremy copp ein
altlinke ist und quasi den weg um
johnson abzulösen durch eine gemäßigte
regierung blockiert so einfach ist das
jerry cotton ist ein altlinke der ich
glaube über 400 mal gegen tony blair
gestimmt hat als hinterbänkler er umgibt
sich mit freunden aus dem aus hamas und
hisbollah und so weiter und so weiter
habe ich mir vielleicht nicht mehr aber
er hat es getan
das heißt er kommt aus seinem bereich
der britischen politik die auf keinen
fall mehrheitsfähig ist und er sagt auch
ich werde die wasserversorgung die
stromversorgung die eisenbahn sonst was
alles nationalisieren also
verstaatlichen
das hat auch eine gewisse unterstützung
aber
für viele branchen der politischen mitte
ist dass es ist ein bürger schrecken und
hätte man auf der linken seite eine
figur wie was heißt sich gordon brown
oder oder es können so eine doch könnte
man durchaus sagen er hat die
finanzkrise zwar 2008 schon halbwegs man
gemanagt hätte man eine eine figur die
halbwegs akzeptabel wäre für die
politische mitte dann würde johnson
dieses kamikaze spielen nicht spielen
können die waagen das wäre wesentlich
größere oder würde sich die opposition
einigen zu sagen unsere aufgabe ist ja
auch den branche zu verhindern es gibt
nur noch einen kandidaten pro wahlkreis
also bald ja eben durch die direktwahl
immer der gewinnt der die relative
mehrheit hat bekommt im parlament sitzt
man konnte ja sagen das was wir jetzt
wollen ist eine vernunft getriebene
britische politik in den nächsten jahren
und deshalb wird es in jedem wahlkreis
in dem die tories antreten und die
treten in allen an nur einen kandidaten
opposition genau das geht aber eben
nicht mit herrn kommen weil herr corbijn
eben auch ein spinner ist denn oder als
für ein spinner gehalten wird den viele
nicht wählen können und nicht wählen wo
wir werden sehen diese forderung ist er
ist jetzt auf dem tisch also dass die
opposition sich verständigt über die
aufstellung von einem beispielsweise
remane oder deal kandidaten und diese
wäre aber nicht sharing korb in heißen
kann aus ihr in den einzelnen
wahlkreisen
dann würde man unter umständen nach
einer neuwahl eine mehrheit bekommen die
sagt ja wir bilden vielleicht eine
eigene regierung aber die
liberaldemokraten haben schon deutlich
gemacht dass kommen für sie auch als
übergangs figur nicht akzeptabel wäre
als als premierminister aber das ist im
grunde genommen die situation
ich erwarte allerdings dass diese
diskussion über bündnis in den
wahlkreisen dynamik bekommt wenn johnson
auf ein deo mit führerschein geht und
das wird im moment diskutiert aber in
dieser woche aus geworfen wurden sich
dieser die dieser bewegung anschließen
würden es ist durchaus möglich und dann
darf man nicht vergessen
mit unseren direktwahl es ist extrem
schwierig ergebnisse der
meinungsumfragen umzusetzen elements
setze es ist regional extrem schwierig
und vor allen dingen gibt es halt dieses
sogenannte margin als also
parlamentssitze die ständig den besitzer
wechseln zwischen den großen parteien
und da kommt es manchmal auf ein paar
stimmen an oder überhaupt dann hörst
passiert oder nicht konnten
entschuldigung
sprechen sie ruhig fertig ich wollte
ganz kurz einmal zusammenfassen an der
stelle wir sind nämlich bald ja also
deswegen wenn die hauptschuldigen
konservativen die 21 einige haben schon
erklärt wie rory stewart oder an bord
dass sie wieder kandidieren als
unabhängige konservative dann würden sie
in ihrem wahlkreis vermutlich die tory
das tolle ergebnis spalten was wiederum
die möglichkeit gibt dass ein
gemässigter politiker vielleicht
liberaldemokraten oder ein gemäßigte
labour figur erhält den satzgewinn
das heißt es ist extrem schwierig zu
sagen was dann passieren
das heißt also ich jetzt sind wir
wirklich schon am ende der kamikaze kurs
von beust johnson geht nur deshalb also
auch deshalb so lange gut weil die
gegenseite eben sich noch nicht
zusammengeschweißt hat noch nicht
abgesprochen hat wie man sich jetzt aber
ich höre da schon einen leichten
hoffnungsschimmer raus dass das
möglicherweise noch passieren kann
in den nächsten tagen und wochen man
weiß es ja nicht so genau aber wir
gucken da auf jeden fall weiter genau
drauf bis hierhin vielen dank wir haben
glaube ich
wesentliche punkte angesprochen und sind
hier im ersten jetzt fertig mit unserem
presseclub zum britischen drama bei uns
geht es aber natürlich auf phoenix und
mit dem wdr 5 weiter mit
nachgefragt im ersten gibt es das
europamagazin dass ich natürlich auch
mit dem wechsel befasst danke bis
hierhin und tschüss
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder auf phoenix und
auf wdr5 mit presseclub nachgefragt zum
britischen drama gibt es einen ausweg
aus der black cit krise wir haben schon
eine dreiviertelstunde lang viele
argumente und mutmaßungen ausgetauscht
und jetzt kriegen zuhörer und zuschauer
das wort und zwar möchte ich gerne noch
mal an die weimarer verhältnisse
anknüpfen die wir ja hier schon am
anfang der sendung besprochen haben und
begrüße dazu sehr herzlich karl-heinz
dorn aus solingen guten mittag herr dorn
ihre frage bitte ja meine frage geht an
herrn lucas das ja auch aufgebracht hat
am anfang der sendung weil das ist ja
auch ich muss gestehen ich bin halt ein
intensives verfolger der geschehen müsse
da ich ja anglophil bin und halt in
irland studiert habe aus den england
also im mittleren zeit gearbeitet habe
das hat ja auch mit dem weimarer
verhältnissen die messi-gala es letztes
jahr aufgebracht ist quasi als hinweis
darauf wenn man heute sind die eu als zu
hart gegen großbritannien halt ist ja
und ich sehe auch dass es halt eben
diesem jahr wieder aufgenommen wird
das heißt was weiß ich der koloss
reichmann darüber schreibt dass man
jetzt halt sebastian haftstrafe die
vermittler hat liest sehen sie das
wirklich so also ich sehe das halt dort
also sehr intensive schalke verfolgt auf
bbc auf den irischen sendern hat es gibt
halt intensive diskussionen erhalten
also ihre frage wäre
wie wahrscheinlich oder wie realistisch
ist dieses szenario der weimarer
verhältnisse was ist also die britische
demokratie also ist halt sozusagen das
halt england sich jetzt als sie den die
engländer als identität sich selber
entdecken halten er schließt das halt
wir als dass sie halt ihre demokrat hier
halt drauf war okay wird das nationale
über das europäische siegen herr dorn
vielen dank für ihre frage herr lukas ja
es ist natürlich so dass briggs ist ein
phänomen des englischen nationalismus
ist das findet man so nicht in
schottland oder in nordirland aber auch
in wales und ich denke natürlich ist das
was jetzt passiert nicht eins zu eins
mit weimar vergleichbar die geschichte
wiederholt sich nicht in dieser form
aber es gibt gewisse strömungen und
ereignisse die schon eine verblüffende
ähnlichkeit haben also wenn man sich
überlegt wir hatten ja auch als ganz
wichtiger punkt bei weimar war war der
wirtschaftskollaps 1929 und wir hatten
in 2008 ein wirtschaftskollaps die
bankenkrise und die reaktion der
britischen regierung auf diese krise war
eine sparpolitik die herr schäuble sehr
gut aussehen lässt also es war extrem
radikal hat den wohlfahrtsstaats sehr
stark zurück geschnitten hat dazu
geführt dass viele menschen im
niedriglohnbereich multi fährt mehrere
jobs haben mussten
und quasi dann geguckt haben was machen
die da oben den geht's gut also das ist
ja quasi diese eifel sucht diese
unzufriedenheit mit dem esta buschmann
und dann haben wir ja noch das gefühl
wie in drei jahre zeit hatten wir diese
dolchstoßlegende an diese legende wird
auch in großbritannien im moment
geschockt gegen die europäische union
wir werden misshandelt kriegen unsere
souveränität weggenommen und und und
das parallele gibt es aber ich sage ja
nicht dass ist eine wiederholung von
weimars ende zu ähnlich aber die
populisten haben den großbritannien im
moment enormen zulauf und die menschen
suchen einfache lösung für extrem
schwierige fragen deswegen war dieses
referendum ein kapitaler fehler von
david cameron
wie kann man sie das herausholen eines
landes was seit 46 jahren mitglied in
der europäischen union war in wenigen
jahren vollziehen wie kann man das land
entkoppeln und erwarten dass es einfach
zu einem positiven ergebnis führt also
die parallelen haben wir jetzt noch mal
angedeutet natürlich muss ich die
geschichte nicht wiederholen aber sie
haben es glaube ich gut beschrieben was
was im moment parallel läuft zu damals
wir gehen jetzt zur wolfgang meyer
hamburg guten mittag einmal ihre frage
bitte das politischen erfolge also das
finde ich unmöglich was da passiert aber
mit der gleichen kritik gut
diese debatten dürften die politische
moral und anständigkeit geführt und es
verdecken einen zarten nach ganz viel
vom university ganzen branche geschichte
liegt nämlich seine abwendung von
dahinter stecken und wirksamen kräften
denn meines erachtens nach und setzt
keine frage sondern eine vermutung
steckt unter diesen haben die
schaltstellen der politik und wirtschaft
musste durch durch nationalisten also
ich jetzt als sternes technicus durch
die nationalistischen populisten in
großbritannien
und da ist das ein verteilungskampf dort
passiert und der praxisbetrieb dazu und
dem theater dollar gemacht wird und die
musiker im alter nimmt die köpfe blutig
reden desto mehr wird abgelenkt von
diesen wirklichen wirtschaftlichen
zielen von von rechten und extrem
rechten finanzwirtschaft in unseren
landwirtschaft müssen die lieben kannst
meines erachtens nach und damit auf den
weg um diese leute an die macht zu
bringen oder den zugriff auf die
wirtschaft und politik
[Musik]
wie sie schon sagten keine wirkliche
frage er eine einschätzung beurteilung
ihrer seite sie haben eine eine eine
überlegung formuliert und ich gebe diese
überlegungen gerne mal an unsere london
spezialistin weiter frau kallweit was
halten sie von dieser überlegung
also wer nutzt das ganze ich antworte
ich jetzt mal relativ simpel darauf der
wirtschaft die in ihrer liste vor kam
jedenfalls nicht alle
wirtschaftsverbände alle sind der
meinung dass dieser bringt eine
katastrophe ist nützt nicht den schotten
den iren den wallisern die diesen exit
kritisch gegenüberstehen
wenn es überhaupt das gibt was sie
beschreiben was ja fast schon richtung
deepstack geht irgendwie dann ist es
sind das englische nationalisten die da
mit versuchen eine nation zu sprengen
ich hoffe dass sie nicht ob sie das war
die einschätzung von frau kahlweit
vielen dank für ihren anruf und ihre
einlassung zu dem thema wir gehen weiter
in der republik zu lothar konrad nach
wetter ruhr guten mittag und ihre frage
bekommen
also wenn ich dem racket ausstieg so
sehe dann ist mir ein europa industrien
heute auf raten oder vielleicht
fehleinschätzungen meiner seite
die wirklichkeit ist doch so dass
england eine demokratische
regierungsform hat es ist weder mit
faschismus oder ähnlichem in der
weimarer zeit zu vergleichen
england tatsächlich europa angeschlossen
es ist eine große schwäche für europa
kann das sein dass es eine große
schwäche für europa wenn europa sagt ein
einzelnes land welches demokratisch
gewählt wurde hat nicht die möglichkeit
auszusteigen
denn es ist keine diktatur in englands
die wirklichkeit ist doch so wenn europa
statt stärke hat muss ich doch davon
ausgehen können dass europa ist auch
klar
keine probleme damit haben kann eingeht
dass irgendein stars aus steigt wenn das
nicht möglich ist dass irgendein stark
aus steigt aus der europäischen union
dann haben wir eine europäische diktatur
und eine europäische diktatur sollten
wir doch auch nicht wirklich greifen
sich doch ein wenig die dass man einen
verein ein turnverein beiträgt grund an
deren leitungen auch erfüllt er konrad
aber großbritannien kann ja aussteigen
sag ich mal es geht jetzt halt um die
vertragsmodalitäten aber hier auf der
auf der europäischen seite haben sich
hier schon gerade 22 reaktionen
bemerkbar gemacht vor weidenfeller
herkommen hat natürlich kann england
austreten darüber reden wir ja die ganze
zeit es gibt einen vertrag wie diese
austritts modalitäten gemacht werden
sollten der ist nicht im parlament im
britischen parlament angenommen worden
aber natürlich kann england gehen wir
reden ja über den black city wir reden
auch über den exit bei die vor das heißt
jeder kann die europäische union
verlassen intelligenter weise tut man so
was mit einem vertrag und mit einer
anschlussregelung eben auch damit die
wirtschaft damit die politik stabil
bleibt und wenn man das nicht schafft
geht man ebenso wie sich das
möglicherweise im moment abzeichnet aber
es kann doch nicht die rede sein von
einer diktatur oder einer
leibeigenschaft der briten in der
europäischen union überhaupt nicht herr
konrad das war die replik von frau
weidenfeld auf ihre überlegung und ihre
ehre ihre meinungsäußerung hier ich
hoffe das hat an der stelle weiter
geholfen jetzt wollen wir ja noch
möglichst viele zuschauer zuhörer dran
nehmen hans jürgen bauer aus siegburg
guten mittag und ihre frage bitte einen
guten mittag auch in die runde
meine frage wäre ganz kurz und
schmerzlos wie ich war oder wie stark
die deg denn wenn ein einzelnes land das
heraus für das sofort sich bald gar
nicht mehr in der eg ist und
letztendlich sogar ein einzelner mensch
die idee
die gesamte institution so vor sich her
tragen kann wie johnson es macht und
wenn ich eine ganz ganz kleine anmerkung
noch machen darf ich hätte unter
umständen die lösung für das problem
denn die fische und in gänsefüßchen oben
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht hat er vor
vielen jahren nordirland annektiert
warum geht laut irland frei kein irland
sowie früher war und das problem der
ausgewählt da haben sie eine frage
vielen dank für ihren angriff erbauer
das ist natürlich eine durchaus
interessante anmerkung ist
wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach
umzusetzen die sich gerade beschrieben
haben aber ich gehe auf ihre frage
zurück nämlich wie kann es sein dass es
ein land und einen menschen so gelingt
europa zu leben haben sie vielleicht
wollen sie darauf antwort na ja bisher
ist europa nicht gelähmt also man hat
sich auch nicht von johnson oder von may
irgendwie treiben lassen sondern der
auswärts vertrag wurde schon auf
initiative der europäischen union und
der verhandlungsführer
banier und bayern konzipiert und dann
auch verabschiedet es sah so aus als
seine frau mary getriebene am ende
allerdings sind wir jetzt in der tat in
der gefahr dass die europäische union
beim nächsten gipfel ein wenig alt
aussieht weil sie sich eben sozusagen
zurücklehnt und sagt schauen wir mal
wasser sondern konnte sicherlich aus
wohl erwogenen taktischen gründen
mir fehlt ein bisschen dabei die
strategie also jetzt ist ja ohnehin die
nächste frage geht ein an stände wenn es
zu einem geregelten praxis käme wie auch
immer wie gehen wir weiter mit
großbritannien um wie soll das künftige
verhältnis sein und da kann es nicht nur
um schadensbegrenzung gehen sondern
müssten sich jetzt schon gedanken machen
auch bussler seite wie wollen wir
künftig einige griechen einander
auskommen
sonst könnte tatsächlich der eindruck
entstehen die europäische union erleidet
diese diesen ausschnitten interessante
beobachtung wir gehen noch mal weiter
und zwar zu herrn kercher aus besigheim
in löchgau herr kircher guten mittag und
ihre frage bitte guten tag wolfgang
kircher als boris johnson den beschluss
gefasst hat die parlamentarier noch mal
die ferien zu schicken musste er vorab
die einwilligung der queen einholen ich
würde einfach pum pum der zusammenarbeit
der regierung zur queen
weil interessiert gibt es eigentlich
irgend eine grenze wo die queen
intervenieren könnte dürfte oder müsste
wenn man zum beispiel über seine
zusammenarbeit mit einer falschen
eindruck nach rechts wo die queen
legitimiert ist eine andere position als
die regierung anzunehmen
vielen dank interessante frage die ich
vielleicht hier auf diese seite gebe ja
also man kann man kann die frage
schlicht mit nein beantworten die
königin macht was die regierung
vorschreibt und wir haben ja die
situation erlebt wo jack vries geflogen
ist nach schottland um mit der königin
zu sprechen auf ihrem schloss balmoral
und im namen des geheim rates
vorzutragen dass der premierminister
sich die auflösung des parlaments für
diese zeit wünscht und die königin hat
dann unterschrieben das hat allerdings
in den sozialen medien in großbritannien
eine große diskussion ausgelöst da waren
etliche leute ziemlich wütend weil sie
geglaubt haben dass die königin anders
hätte entscheiden müssen
und seitdem wird immer wieder gesagt ja
diese garantien sind eigentlich nicht da
und wir dachten immer die wären da und
das war dann natürlich die stunde der
republikaner unter uns die dann gesagt
haben warum brauchen wir eine brauchen
werner königin wenn sie in diese
situation nicht tätig wird der einzige
moment wo die königin tatsächlich das
sagen hätte wäre wenn sie einen neuen
premierminister
mit der bildung einer regierung
beauftragen würde und dann natürlich
entscheiden muss wer hat überhaupt die
chance eine mehrheit im parlament zu
finden das ist glaube ich der einzige
moment im ganzen prozess indem sie so
was wie eine art verhülltes mit sprache
auch dort nimmt sie normalerweise den
rat des scheidenden scheidenden
premierministers an ihn zu meinen
lebzeiten ist es nur einmal passiert und
zwar als harold macmillan zum
premierminister gemacht hat stadtrat
butler der eigentlich dran gewesen wäre
und der favorit wäre das war ja ende der
50er jahre
also länger her
naja vielleicht spielt ja dann die queen
auch wieder eine rolle in dem
zusammenhang den wir kurz zu ende
unserer sendung im ersten skizziert
hatten
inwiefern kann sich denn das lager das
boris johnson im moment gegenüber steht
möglicherweise noch einen anders
positionieren also das jetzt tun wir
haben die schwierigkeiten mit dem
oppositionsführer corvin besprochen das
war jetzt der versuch nochmal darauf zu
blicken vielleicht gibt es ja doch noch
eine für alle seiten irgendwie
glimpfliche ausgangssituation aus diesem
chaos hinaus damit sind wir am ende der
sendung angelangt wir haben hoffentlich
einige fragen der zuschauer hier auch
beantworten können ich bedanke mich auf
jeden fall ganz herzlich für interesse
machen sie es gut bis zum nächsten mal
und einen schönen sonntag noch
[Musik]